[Music]
so they are going to play a game in iowa
next year between the yankees and the
white sox at or about the site of the
field of dreams the legendary
kevin costner movie ray leota from
goodfellas played shoeless joe jackson
in that film it inspired today's draft
here's what we're gonna do
we are dr and this one this can go in a
lot of different directions oh yes again
this is gonna be where you would want
the nfl to play a gimmick game like the
baseball field of dreams contest coming
up august 13 of 2020. so no gimmick here
rig coin toss go i should just let you
take the first pick but go ahead let's
see if i get lucky today and win this
yeah let's go tails i think kristin's
going to have some sympathy for me being
on the road working so hard oh kristen
how dare you how about that how about
that good you can have it today
this is one of those days where it
doesn't matter there's there's there's
no obvious pick it's only limited by our
creativity
do you like field of dreams the movie
because it's one of my favorite sports
movies you like it it was it's one of
those
i i got to be careful here because this
is going to be all field of dreams
nostalgia it's one of those movies that
when you watched it at the time it was
great but it for some reason there are
some movies from the 80s that hold up
well like ferris bueller holds up well
other movies i don't know what it is but
there's an indefinable quality where it
doesn't carry across the same i don't
know what it doesn't seem as good all
right i don't know if it's the camera
the lighting whatever the overall
production value but it's one of those
ones that when you watch it after the
fact i don't think it's as good the
natural holds up baseball movie from the
80s that i loved field of dreams doesn't
it just there's something about i don't
know if it's the music i don't know what
it is but it just or maybe you just have
a greater memory i don't know we're
taking up all the time yeah yeah hurry
up viewing your picture dreams 30 years
after the fact all right i i'm going to
go and i'm going to keep this in the
family since we've got part of the
nascar package here they have an infield
at daytona that is big enough for
football they've been talking about
playing football in daytona college not
pro why not fill that place up with more
people than have ever been to a football
game in the history of mankind and play
an nfl game on that infield of daytona
have the jaguars and bucks get together
they have a hard time filling up their
stadiums i think they would fill up
daytona for a football game an nfl game
played in the infield there how about
that that's a good one i like that
actually to add to that i'd like the
cars to be going around the track while
they're playing be kind of cool too see
if they can deal with the crowd noise
and everything but i i like that idea i
did not think of that uh it would look
funny you know because the infield is so
huge but you're right they would set
records as far as attendance uh in the
history of the nfl for a game they could
probably not great sight lines right not
great sight lines but what the hell
you're there you're having a good time
what the hell is right okay you know
where i want to go i'm going to the
north pole first okay i'm going to the
north pole for a game lately in the
summer they've had some 90 degree days
up there you know why because this
climate change thing is real yeah here
we go
i think it's a great way to
get everybody knowledge about what's
going on up there okay because there's a
lot of issues all right but yeah the
weather is conducive to it in the summer
not time so okay i know i went a little
crazy there but i had to just get it off
captain is here there he is
saving the north pole
yeah so i think that could be funny they
can find some way to find some field or
whatever and we don't need stands for
that game just get a few camera cameras
up there north pole climate change made
it warmer they can do it
play it on a on a big piece of glacier
that broke off i mean i don't want to
make light of the problem it's a real
problem yeah it's just funny how you get
worked up for halloween you need to be
captain planning you need to dye your
hair green okay i might get a captain
planet i might do that
all right well since we're getting nuts
let's get really nuts and this next one
i mean th this is kind of a twist on the
uh the cliche that we hear anytime
there's a complaint about the quality of
the turf or the grass or it rained or
it's this or is the field going to be
ready invariably someone says we'll play
this game on a parking lot all right
fine tackle football on a parking lot
let's go put your money where your mouth
is i mean it can't be that worse than
the turf your dad played on all those
years it's basically a parking lot that
was painted green let's play on a
parking lot guys let's see how tough you
are how about that that really not
conducive to the whole push for player
health and safety but you hear that all
the time oh we're playing a parking lot
fine dude maybe they could just at least
put a rubber mat down or something like
that so they don't know
blisters and skid burns all over
themselves to where they're dealing with
like band-aids all season long because
they've been like burned by the ground
so much so okay
i'm okay with that you're in crazyville
i'm in crazyville i want a game at a
prison okay that's what i want i want in
lieu of like longest yard i want to
bring a game to wherever that can bring
it biggest prison in our country
something like that uh maybe bring a
little joy to those guys lives who
certainly have made mistakes we know
that but uh
you know i want to see like the fence
around the field and the inmates around
the fence watching the game just like
the longest yard movie that to me with
the barbed wire on top i think that
would like kind of look really cool bob
wire yeah
i did i did i did barbed wire excuse me
uh that would be cool like you know like
johnny uh johnny cash going back to what
was that the fulton county prison when
he did that day folsom prison oh yeah to
do that that would uh i could i could
get down with that i'd tune in to watch
that
and let me tell you the
the reason he went back there and he had
so many concerts at prisons i mean these
are guys who
are living under subhuman conditions yes
they have to constantly fear violence
the conde the water is horrible
everything about it is bad it's prison
right and it gives these guys something
to get through the day something to look
forward to something to enjoy and for
that reason yeah for that reason hey uh
you know i don't know how much revenue
they'd make off of it but uh it's not
like they're going to make much off of
playing in the north pole either all
right let you know what we've taken this
thing next level i've got i've got some
i didn't know how this was going to go
i've got some semi plausible ideas and
then i've got the let's go to crazyville
if we're going to go to crazyville let's
go to the ultimate crazyville let's go
right they're moving a team to nevada
let's get the raiders before and they
could have done it this year before the
the new stadium is ready area 51 baby
they're going to storm area 51. they got
plenty of flat land there play a
football game at area 51 right the
aliens can watch from above i i you know
we're going to go nuts let's go nuts
there's plenty of i've been reading the
book about area 51. it it's a little
thick it's a little like reading a
textbook there's some amazing stuff in
there about how it really was used and
why there were so many rumors about ufos
and flying saucers and whatnot but
i did learn there's plenty of flat land
plenty of space to build a temporary
stadium and play a football it looks
like there is yeah i've seen like you
know little pictures and things where
yeah you're right flat land certainly uh
it's mike i mean so you're reading this
book you think it's real though i mean
are there like any inklings of like
there is ufo stuff stored there no no
nothing no the the no the the ufos i
don't want to spoil it for anybody who
may want to read it but there's there
really is a legitimate explanation for
the sightings of ufos and that there's
one and i'm waiting for it to come back
around to it because i still got a way
to go but there's a revelation made
early on that gave me chills so if you
haven't read the area 51 book by andy
jacobson it is it is a slow read you
really got to focus but i'm telling you
it's worth the price for something you
see in the first couple chapters there's
been some videos released lately like of
navy pilots and things who have seen
these unidentified objects look it up
it's a real thing i mean i saw it on the
news like a month ago so uh you know i
don't know i i some i believe in ufos am
i crazy for that i'm crazy anyways we
know that you're crazy for a lot of
reasons what's your next you're just
filibustering because you have no idea
how to top area 51. no well i do i do
because we know we like to support our
troops right we're all about supporting
the troops nfl aircraft carrier yes i'm
saying an aircraft carrier it doesn't
have to be out in the middle of like the
baltic sea or like in you know the
middle of the atlantic but why can't we
have it like you know port side like it
is in san diego or something like that
can't they find a way to put some field
turf on that huge aircraft carrier and
get the armed forces there around it on
the aircraft carrier well you know some
planes in the background i think that'd
be really cool if they could figure out
to make it safe a safe surface for the
players there yeah you why did you say
that why did you say don't say aircraft
carrier was that on your list or you
just knew it well no i'm just i just
first of all i don't know the aircraft
carrier is big enough but i guess that
it is i just you know it it it it
everybody
planes can take off and land on it i
think we can throw footballs on it it's
got to be big enough it adds a new
element to the whole sideline catch
right you want to be very
that's a careful way down um you know
but they've played basketball games on
aircraft carriers and i remember a few
years ago they had one and they had to
actually stop it because there was
condensation on the on the wood floor i
mean that wouldn't be an issue with a
with a turf field i just i uh
i'm intrigued by it that's not a bad one
i thought of it i thought it's not going
to be big enough but then i i remember
those aircraft carriers are pretty big
probably at least 100 yards by 53. i
would think so
all right um well that was it okay so
what else did you have on your list that
wasn't like crazy over the top i i did
like along the lines of the aircraft
carrier i thought about like doing it at
some you know army base something like
that you know uh somewhere around the
country that was really all i had i only
had four things so like there was a few
times there i was like oh gosh i hope he
doesn't pick what i have because i got
nothing left after this so that was all
i had
i'm surprised given your connection to
the notre dame broadcast you didn't
suggest that
i didn't know her name yep if if the nfl
expands to 17 regular season games
giving them 16 neutral site games and if
there aren't 16 new
foreign games that can be played right
you could play a game at notre dame you
could play a game in an art play a game
at yeah exactly so right that was on my
list also look there was a time when the
steelers played uh on the same field
where the pirates played there was a
time when the steelers played at forbes
field part of their home games where the
pirates used to play why not play a
steelers game at pnc park that place is
beautiful yeah great backdrop of the
pittsburgh skyline right but but you
know we we got we got a little nuts
early on so yeah and also the astrid the
astrodome is still standing put a texans
game in there let's have some fun
one more game in the astrodome oh it's
amazing to see the astrodome in person
it was such a big deal like what was
that late 60s early 70s and you see it
now and it was a big deal then and now
it's like
you know it's like leftover crap
compared to some of these buildings you
see now
all right uh we're gonna take a break
one return there's more preseason action
coming up over the balance of the
weekend we'll talk about some storylines
that you may be paying attention to
before we go though quick summary of the
draft i have for my gimmick space for an
nfl game daytona international speedway
infield a parking lot literally area 51.
this is ridiculous sims has the north
pole a prison like in the longest yard
and an aircraft carrier your best pick
was your last one we'll be back with
more pft library after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports